are you excited for cyberpunk 2077 well
developer CD projekt red's latest move
has upset a few fans I'm Tony and this
is your trademarked GameSpot news update
yes The Witcher developer did file a
trademark for the term cyberpunk in
Europe considering that term has been
used to describe a ton of works
including Robocop laid runner and ghost
in the shell some people aren't happy
and even though the studio doesn't plan
on filing against anyone for simply
using the term it took to Twitter to
defend its move saying cyberpunk 2077 is
a massive project and we've already
invested a lot of hard work and
resources into making it the best game
we can we have to make sure we are the
only entity that can use its exact name
and naming scheme the reason for our
registration is to protect us from any
unlawful actions of our competitors CD
Projekt has held the same trademark in
the US since 2012 but we still don't
have any solid release window for
cyberpunk 2077 maybe we'll hear
something at e3 but for more sci-fi
right now you can check out our Mass
Effect Andromeda post patch graphics
comparison
[Music]